sandra chevrier vos oeuvres ont voyagé
partout dans le monde ces femmes
masquées de super-héros ces femmes nous
ont rapporté aussi beaucoup d'argent
comment vous avez réalisé ce grand rêve
qui n'était pas un rêve parce que
en fait je ne savais pas que c'est
possible d'avoir une carrière d'artiste
au québec depuis que je suis tout petit
en fait j'allais dans les galeries joyel
et je voyais les hommes mais je
comprenais pas que c'est un métier qui
pourrait être possible quand j'ai eu mon
fils que dix ans maintenant
quand j'étais enceinte en fait j'ai pris
la décision de retourner travailler
je travaillais comme un chef dans un
restaurant de sushis donc c'est ça j'ai
pris un grand risque
j'en remercie mon fils parce que je sais
pas si je fais tout ce que je suis
aujourd'hui sans lui ça a été vraiment
beaucoup de courage qui m'a apporté
[Musique]
c'est quand même une belle métaphore
parce que vous avez toujours peint des
femmes emprisonnées
oui il ya dix ans vous avez tout
abandonner pour retrouver une certaine
liberté artistes oui quel est le message
derrière du message très féministe et
oui en fait c'est devenu sommet au
départ pour moi c'est vraiment je les
représente et le côté humain du super
héros parce qu'on vit dans une société
en fait qu on se met tellement de
pression nous mêmes sur nos épaules la
société nous mais aussi des pressions
sur les épaules
être une femme émancipée donc on doit
réussir
et dans notre carrière et être une mère
parfaite une épouse parfaite faire le
ménage est restée souriante et toujours
de bonne humeur en fait puis c'est
beaucoup de pression
d'où vous est venu le flash de créer ses
personnages
je suis allé au marché aux puces pour
acheter des comic books pour la chambre
de mon fils que je l'air à couvrir
immeubles en fête un meuble ikea qui
malheureusement a brisé dans fait
heureusement parce que j'étais pris avec
ses comics boucle puis j'ai juste
ateliers en fait par rapport à cette
série là j'avais déjà commencé et la
puissance que pourrait apporter
justement le message des super-héros
juxtaposés sur ces visages là mais aussi
le côté esthétique du papier couleurs
vibrantes très rapidement
en fait chaque oeuvre que je faisais se
rendait immédiatement c'est un conte de
fée vous vivez en quelque sorte parce
que vos oeuvres seront instantanément
vous avez vendu 350 sérigraphie en 15
secondes
oui oui ça va arrêter du jour au
lendemain mais quand j'ai commencé la
série de tout de suite les galeries de
partout à travers le monde ont commencé
à m'écrire qui voulait travailler avec
moi qui qui m'offrait justement des
expositions solos chose que j'avais
jamais fait avant donc ce soir ça a été
tout c'est de prendre des décisions et
j'ai eu des personnes clim city ont été
des guides de vos amis c'est alicia keys
oui comment se développer sa nouvelle
amitié ça vous aider également pour
votre carrière
oui je te mangerais peu près au moment
j'ai commencé à délaisser facebook et
comprendre qu'un style en mettant un
outil parce qu'essentiellement fait pour
un artiste de nos jours alice tient des
cours à mon travail puis est vraiment
tombé en amour avec mes oeuvres puis
l'intermédiaire de son mari qui m'a
contacté qui ont appelé dimanche soir on
a commencé à communiquer en fait puis
rapidement ils vont acheter une oeuvre 2
3 5e une invitée chez eux
je suis allée sont venus à mes
expositions alicia m'envoie des cadeaux
c'est vraiment une belle amitié pour moi
ça m'a aussi permis justement de ils
sont devenus comme un genre de clé par
rapport à vers un monde qui est
tellement difficile d'accéder au fait
que ce soit les gens de la musique où ce
que ce soit de leur entourage des gens
qui sont ici millionnaires milliardaires
puis quand tu rentres dans des
collections comme ça que l'âge la
personne en fait plus vraiment s'offrir
tout ce qu'elle pouvait s'offrir mieux
que ce que ce soit des oeuvres de jean
michel basquiat des mineurs puis il
décide d'acheter sandra chevrier c'est
quand même assez incroyable sadr achevée
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
du